so my thing like like like even now  people  oh you're so successful you do this you  make this it's not about that for me My  Soul Dream was to be able to buy my  mother anything she wants even to this  day that's why I work hard right so  like all the stuff you said I own it's  cool but it was my mom's birthday and  she don't even like Louie purses I said  let's take a ride in you know the bag  2000 no baby don't buy that get two of  them mom like that right there is is  what being wealthy and successful is for  me so when I'm playing I'm on that Court  you can't outplay me because if you are  you're taking my mother's house away  and I can't have that so I will damn  near kill you powerful I will damn  nearly kill you before I let you take my  money wow so when I'm wow when I'm  inside those lines unbelievable when I'm  inside those lines there's nothing  anybody can do ever